did we hurt your feelings i'm so sorry
if we did some pretty major actors
missed out on voicing these disney roles
whether the production went in a
different direction or the performer
backed out years before brave actually
went into production reece witherspoon
had been attached and set to play merida
the actress was extremely excited about
it and the team was looking forward to
having her talent on board however she
didn't quite fit the bill because of one
pretty key issue
with the film being set in scotland
witherspoon needed to whip out a solid
scottish accent but once she realized
what she sounded like she knew she
couldn't do it justice and stepped down
from the job i tried to do a scottish
accent once really it was bad i had to
quit the movie you did that's when kelly
mcdonald got brought into the movie and
since she really is scottish the accent
wasn't an issue i am merida first born
descendant of clandenbrock fairly early
on in the development process the
creative team behind tangled wanted to
experiment with a quirkier less typical
disney princess in rapunzel and that's
when amy poehler's name was thrown into
the ring and she was seriously being
considered the competition was stiff
with an impressive array of actresses
auditioning including rhys witherspoon
natalie portman but ultimately what if
it's not everything i dreamed it would
be it was mandy moore who brought the
frying pan wielding rapunzel to life
because i've been dreaming about them my
entire life we've all known buzz
lightyear to be voiced by tim allen no
no no go go just go i'll catch up but he
originally nearly had the voice of two
other pretty big names jim carrey and
billy crystal crystal didn't actually
audition getting a straight offer from
the team but he turned it down and
unsurprisingly it remains a major career
regret for him when carrie actually did
go through the audition process he was a
front-runner but once the team heard
allen they found their buzz
that is until chris evans came along for
the prequel a special guy while anika
noni rose brought an incredible
performance to life playing tiana and
the princess and the frog another singer
had been considered before rose booked
the gig alicia keys actually auditioned
three times making it very far in the
process
but she wasn't the only major name in
the mix we're talking the likes of
jennifer hudson tyra banks evidently the
actresses being auditioned were nothing
short of fierce maybe next time
among the many incredible performers
considered to play princess tiana was
none other than the queen herself
beyonce
the singer was very interested in
playing the part and had even been in
contact with disney but she didn't want
to have to audition for the part so
disney refused to offer it to her while
it was a miss for tiana luckily we got
to hear her is nala and the live-action
lion king a few years later simba we
need to leave
before she landed her role as anna and
frozen kristen bell was up to play
rapunzel and tangled even though that
gig didn't work out the process was well
worth it since it helped in securing her
role in frozen down the line two sisters
one mind after giving an incredible read
for rapunzel the casting director was
impressed and made sure bell got to meet
chris buck who was set to direct a
future disney film that bell was perfect
for you know the one
kristin wasn't the only frozen star that
auditioned to play rapunzel though idina
menzel aka elsa was also being
considered for tangled okay well what do
you want to do somewhere out there is a
version of finding nemo with a marlin
voiced by none other than william h macy
the actor not only auditioned for the
role but he booked the job and actually
went on to record an entire cut of the
film
while he gave loads of time and effort
to the project ultimately the feedback
from the first watchers from disney
wasn't so great and a major change had
to be made unfortunately for macy this
meant his voice was cut from the film
and all the dialogue was redone by
albert brooks they're natural predators
bill murray's rejection from monsters
inc wasn't due to any lack of talent but
a wild instance of miscommunication pete
doctor was a huge fan of his audition
and even went so far as to try to reach
marie to talk to him about doing the
movie for whatever reason at the time
the actor was relying on a 1 800 number
and an answering machine instead of an
agent or manager making reaching the
performer extremely difficult the team
just assumed that maybe he wasn't
interested anymore and unfortunately
that was that oh yeah crazy
the role of hades in hercules was
actually originally written with jack
nicholson's voice in mind early concept
art even being inspired by his actual
looks the actor was game to take on the
role that is however until the money
talk began nicholson was expecting a
bigger paycheck that was more in line
with what he'd been making doing major
roles by this point disney is huge and
certainly not strapped for cash but they
wouldn't pay up so nicholson parted ways
with the project james woods stepped in
at the last minute but managed to bring
a stellar performance as the
fast-talking fun lord of the dead
ladies
i am so sorry that i'm mate before he
rose to fame as the stellar comedic
actor we all know him to be jim carrey
had auditioned to play prince eric in
the little mermaid in the late 80s this
was so early on in his career that
carrie was still pretty unknown so this
audition to play a leading disney prince
was a huge deal christopher daniel
barnes wound up snagging the job and
shortly after carrie's career blew up
after starring in in living color
it's pretty hard to imagine anyone else
but robin williams voicing the legendary
genie in aladdin
just be yourself no shade to will smith
who brought an amazing performance but
williams is the genie we all grew up
with that being said
multiple other comedians were being
considered john goodman john candy eddie
murphy steve martin and even martin
short all of them had done readings of
the material and were likely candidates
what earned williams the job was a
stand-up routine he did seen by the
disney team and after that all bets were
off i never did it i am not at fault
before scott weinger took on the role of
aladdin the part was meant for michael j
fox aladdin was even originally designed
to look like him once the team decided
to go with weinger on the job
adjustments were made to how aladdin
looked and instead of making him appear
like the actor they went with a tom
cruise vibe
nathan lane gave an epic performance as
timon and the lion king but before that
casting was settled he was being
considered for a much smaller role one
of the hyenas after hearing multiple
actors audition lane was given a
character upgrade and booked to play the
cheeky meerkat whoopi goldberg and
cheech marin ended up voicing the hyenas
instead banzai what have we got here
i don't know
what are you thinking lily tomlin
auditioned for the role she booked the
role but then she lost it the actress
was originally slated to play edna mode
in the incredibles but during a
read-through brad bird had filled in for
the actress who wasn't available at the
time once the team heard how hilarious
his read was they changed their minds
and tomlin was dropped from the project
this one probably stung pretty badly
to impress you must express
eddie murphy gave a memorable
performance as mushu and mulan but the
character actually began as a different
animal before mushu was a dragon he was
actually a two-headed serpent named yin
and yang not only did it have two names
and two heads it also had two different
actors voicing it joe pesci and richard
dreyfuss were meant to give life to the
snake but once they settled on one voice
and a one-headed dragon pesci wasn't
quite the right match the actor was
brought in and recorded some dialogue
but the casting wasn't as solid as when
he played one half of yin and yang
okay let's get this show on the road
pick it get the bags these characters
and films could have been very different
but ultimately the actors who did voice
these roles gave amazing performances
however we're definitely curious to hear
some of those audition tapes or even the
entire finding nemo film with william h
macy as marlin